it turns out in the jewish religion
that you're a man after you've been bar
mitzvahed so i was like i really gotta
give this up and so i didn't do it for a
year
[Music]
i'm gary goldman i'm here to answer the
internet all right would you rather have
your girl be able to see or hear
everything you do
when she's not around i'd rather her
hear it uh because i
at least keep it quiet but
[Laughter]
would you rather be a pig and be able to
orgasm for 30 minutes or be a lion and
be able to have
sex 60 times
a day oh i'd rather be a 30-minute
orgasm yeah yeah yeah
60 times a day is uh how are you how are
you building society
that's why that's why the lions are
still living in caves because they're
having sex 60 times a day
and
yeah and the pig ran a city what's worse
people who run marathons or polar plunge
people i think polar plunge people are
more likely to be psychotic right yeah
yeah
and marathon people you got to give them
credit for finishing that insane race
and never walking the same again
they'll never be able to take the stairs
after that day okay would you rather be
half your height or double your weight
oh my gosh i'd rather be
half my height i think that would be
healthier and easier you would be
yeah and easier to count for you yeah
i'd be able to i'd be able to fly a
coach
so
yes would save me a lot of money is
flossing it in public acceptable no
never i think flossing should have the
same type of privacy that uh a deuce has
you should you should go into the
bathroom you should yeah you should lock
the door and uh and then you should
squeegee the mirror afterwards i think
cutting your fingernails in public
should be yeah
i'm a nail i'm a nail biter so i yeah
yeah
yeah and why because larry bird used to
do that on the bench
so i was like if larry burke didn't bite
his nails on the bench why can't if you
were murdered
who would be the most likely suspect
wow
i mean i i i it's always the wife
but i don't i don't do anything that
would make her murder me but she has the
most access to me she's with me all day
long whatever i did i deserved it
yeah for ten thousand dollars would you
spend two days carrying around a human
looking japanese robot that you had to
introduce people as your girlfriend
this is a question not for man in my
banana republic tax bracket
i'm doing i'm doing pretty well so i
don't need the ten thousand dollars
uh for for two days
uh work so i would turn it down but when
i was coming up in comedy i would have
done this in a second and absolutely
introduced her as my girlfriend as long
as it wasn't a japanese robot in a
stereotypical like this is offensive
i don't want to do that because you're
not out you're not outliving that you'll
always be the guy who walked around with
something that was the the japanese
equivalent of um
have you ever seen the the the harry
potter with where the the bankers are
clearly jewish stereotypes
unbelievable are there sacred days when
you refuse to masturbate um
i would i would say that uh funerals
tragedies i once went and this is this
is a feat all of eighth grade
all of eighth grade because or maybe it
was sev whatever it was after i had been
bar mitzvahed it turns out in the jewish
religion
that uh you're a man after you've been
bar mitzvahed so i was like i really
gotta give this up and so i didn't do it
for a year
and then uh
prime time prime
but then but it turned out it wasn't
prime there was a time where i would
even have a a
a harder sex drive where i wasn't able
to resist and i and i and i finally i
finally i finally gave in you were like
13 years old yeah yeah
yeah
i have to grow up stop playing with
myself
[Applause]
and the other thing was and then when i
started going in again i would just
apologize to god profusely after i
finished it was like i i don't know
what's happening i made that promise
i've broken it because i i
yeah
i i have this there's still around your
ankles this just this old yeah this old
testament uh relationship with god where
i'm just apologizing all the time would
you accept a million dollars to be a to
be deported from the u.s you can never
come back but you get to take one person
no the million dollars is i'm probably
worth between 89 and 96 000 right now
if you count my security deposit as an
asset
um
so uh i i would i i that's enough it's
enough for me i have several streaming
services
and
and i subscribe to more magazines than
than i ever would have when i was a kid
having sports illustrated was like the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
but now i get like the new yorker and
s.i and and
the athletic i mean i i i uh there's
there's no book i i yearn for like
every time i'm like i like this book i
read a sample i like it i buy it
yeah i'm i'm very my wife is not
materialistic i do not know how i didn't
go what do you think is the fanciest
thing you have this that you own is the
the most uh expensive or i have a i have
a 20 20 honda insight
yeah like that's true it's a hybrid so
that's like the fanciest thing i have
but when i when i when i tell you my
wife and i are not um
we're not materialistic at all thank god
are you an [ __ ] if you sit in the
back and don't talk to an uber driver if
he tries to talk to you and you don't
talk to him but i mean i
i
love the rating system where they rate
you and so i i bring them water and a
kind bar
and and they say where to i say where do
you where do you want to go
let's take some errands would you rather
your girlfriend get a notification every
time you watched porn with a description
or a notification of where you are
at all times i mean either one i'm i'm
an open book with my wife on this so
yeah it doesn't really matter and i
gotta tell you i um
i have a pretty good imagination
um so i don't use a lot of i don't use
right off the top yeah i don't use a lot
of a lot of porn i i've developed enough
of a rolodex in my head of my um
yeah
yeah so
listen i'm not i'm not i'm not against
it
i'm not against it but they can't get as
specific as i can they they don't they
don't yeah there's there's no uh there's
no um hebrew school confirmation
there's uh in in porn there's there's
there's no that ta from the sophomore
you're a college
that that it's hard to forget so yeah
they uh as specific as they get they
don't know my life as well as i do
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon